[Music]
hello
Wendell welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
devious advice and meanwhile the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John what is the elephant in the room
all right ready Hank on three one two
three
AFC Avani wait what was yours
giovanni is the name of the of the hair
product in my shower
you're obsessed that is that is giving
my wife a hard time Hank really does not
like this hair product called Giovanni
because of the way that it talks about
people's hair he feels that it is
nagging on human hair which he thinks
his bad form for a product I don't think
John is too it is exactly what it's
exactly what it's doing it's like maybe
my hair is limp and lifeless maybe I do
need Giovanni eco-chic haircare and I'm
not saying it's bad shampoo saying it's
bad marketing it says with horsepower
expanders to increase body and shine
while infusing weightless texture
texture can't be weightless what's a
horsepower expander hair is supposed to
not be alive these are all great points
Hank I'm for one I'm really glad that my
hair is limp and lifeless because if it
worked I would have liked yet another
organism that isn't me on my body to
contend with yeah what I need is erect
vital hair no I don't want that no Hank
the actual elephant in the room this
week of course it has to be AFC
Wimbledon the June AFC Wimbledon we
can't enter the pod can't wait till the
other podcast we have a we have a level
one AFC Wimbledon emergency announcement
every now and again Hank Wimbledon
cannot wait until the end of the podcast
AFC Wimbledon through a beautiful and
excruciating nil-nil draw have ensured
that they will be spending another
season in the third tier of English
football oh my gosh oh my gosh just an
unbelievable turn of
Vence meanwhile Milton Keynes not not
gonna be in Ligue 1 an hour in fact take
I got this wonderful email from Jessica
it's the single best email receive
something for the end of the podcast
here John and Hank I was looking at a
map of London recently and I found
Wimbledon and saw where plough Lane is
and where Kings meadow is and it helped
me visualize some of the places that
you've talked about on the podcast but I
searched and searched and I could not
find Milton Keynes on that map of London
so my question is where is Milton Keynes
oh wait never mind I found them there in
Ligue 2 now Jessica Jessica
I don't know what you do for a living
but you should be in the burn business
oh that's hot that's hard John that's
hard Hank as you know I don't like to
negative route but I also don't believe
in absolutes of any kind there are
always exceptions yeah obviously because
it seems it seems that you negative
route pretty constantly this first
question it comes from Ari who asks dear
hanga John if the full moon happens
every 28 days or every four weeks why
doesn't it always fall on the same day
that week the last two full moons have
both been visible on a Sunday but I
remember the one in January happening on
a Wednesday or something what's going on
does the moon take days off work is it a
ploy by the government to hypnotize us
please help me understand my beautiful
space girlfriend feeling starry re oh my
well I mean I I didn't know Ari was in
love with the moon but it's helpful I
think that's gonna change the way that I
answered the question right you not an
expert in this Hank but my suspicion is
that it's not exactly 28 days your
suspicion is correct John yes it in fact
is I think 29 and a half-ish days it's
not of course precisely 29 and a half
like the the moon doesn't care how long
a week is the moon doesn't care how long
a day is the moon doesn't care like
that's that system is completely
separate from the earth-sun system so
they are not linked together in any way
which is part of why our calendar is so
messed up because we had a lunar
calendar that we were trying to go by
and we were also trying to match it with
days when we were also trying to match
that was the years and none of those
things have anything to do with each
other
right which is super weird but it makes
me wonder Hank what does the moon care
about if it doesn't care about days so
yeah does it care about all of us
oh no the well the so now I have the
official number John okay
the synodic month hmm has a period of
twenty nine point five three zero five
nine days and I would like to say that
that is not that is taken out to a
certain number of significant digits but
it doesn't in there it goes out forever
right it is one of those things that is
a infinite has an infinite number and
and also that number changes as time
goes on I want a sequel to that Joan
Osborne song what if God was one of us
called what if the moon was one of us
that imagines three moon as having
thoughts and feelings whereas I think
that the moon is just a cold dead rock
and it's really hard to get excited
about cold dead rocks but you do your
best I do my best
actually I have news from Mars this week
Hank its first time ever on the pod I've
got the Mars news or at least some Mars
news so we might we might double the
down on the Mars news this next question
comes from Megan who writes Dear John
and Hank it was my 21st birthday last
man I got quite a lot of money from my
family around 250 pounds which I think
translates to fourteen thousand seven
hundred dollars because this was a big
birthday I felt like I should spend the
money on something special and something
that I could keep so I decided to think
about it the only problem is I'm still
thinking about it and the money's been
sitting in a book for almost a year now
huh
that seems like an odd place to keep
your money Megan but I'm not here to
judge you do either if you have any
advice about what I could spend this
money on well first of all it's your
21st birthday I don't know maybe you
should spend it starting a bank account
yeah no I mean I would encourage you to
find an institution other than a book to
put your money in unless it's you're
putting it in the Fault in Our Stars or
Turtles all the way down and it's just
sort of like an honor an honor that
you're stowing upon John he doesn't know
well it doesn't need to know about it
but just it's like a it's like a gift to
the gift of the book God let me throw
this out there Megan one
thing you could do as a sort of
investment strategy would be with to
take you 250 pounds and turn it into
like 30 copies of Turtles all the way
down oh hold on to those 30 copies after
all delete the leap No
what are you what this is the terrible
investment strategy it's a great way to
turn 250 pounds into like maybe 18
pounds 50 here's I you know there are
things you need you spend money all the
time you might just spend the money on
the things you spend money on and then
you will not have then you will have
more money in your bank account and more
things that make your life easier but
what you could do if you want your
people who gave you this money for your
21st birthday to feel appreciated is
maybe be like okay what like what maybe
I want to like learn how to play guitar
and you spend 250 pounds on like like a
few months of guitar lessons and then
you're like I can now play 4 chords
which is all that you really need to
play most of the songs and everybody can
you can basically say this is a gift
that was given to me by a bunch of
people and now I for the rest of my life
I can play guitar poorly which is way
better than not being able to play
guitar at all I think that's good advice
if anybody I I think that's I think
that's good advice and it Hank knows of
what he speaks he of course has built a
proper musical career around only being
able to play four chords I also think
that you could maybe just save the money
that's you haven't have it for a rainy
day so either you're gonna learn to play
guitar or you're gonna save the money or
I still think it's an option on the
table you're gonna buy like 25 copies of
turtles all the way down or or you can
sign up for audible which we'll talk
about later in this podcast this next
question comes from Elizabeth who asks
dear Hank and John I'll be graduating
college in a little less than a month
and I've somehow managed to be
graduating summa [ __ ] laude which is
exciting I only have one problem I've
never remembered what the answer
actually is is it pronounced lod or loud
a or some other way like latte or just
loud I took Latin in a high school and I
feel like I should know the answer to
this but the truth continues to elude
I mean elude Amy please help not lizard
breath Elizabeth kortner well Hank this
is an area of expertise for both of us
because we both graduated [ __ ] laude not
to brag
we did not you're making that up you may
have I graduated [ __ ] laude by the
absolute skin of my teeth not summa [ __ ]
laude like fellows yeah I grab right no
regular [ __ ] laude the lowest of the
Laudes yeah I also got the lowest of
bulow days it was a less good sash there
was a sash but it was less exciting
right I think I needed a 3.45 GPA and
thanks to a B+ in Buddhist thought in
practice I ended up with the 3.46 so
elizabeth here's my advice you need to
ask everyone in your life including all
of your potential employers how they
would pronounce Lao day as a way of
explaining that you graduated from
college summa [ __ ] laude right yeah yeah
you're like it's a way it's a super
great way to just introduce the topic
you don't want to just like tattoo it on
your arm and be like do you know well I
got this new tattoo cuz I'm a big deal
you got to be like wait I'm confused
about a thing help me out and when
they're like what do you want to know
and it's cuz Oh cuz I got the best
possible thing you can get right ya know
it's like when you ask somebody where
they went to college and they say oh I
went to college outside Boston and then
you'd barf a little bit in the back of
your mouth and then you say where and
then they say Harvard well you ask or
they just brought it up usually actually
you didn't ask but they're like when I
was in college outside Boston and then
you barf in the back of your mouth and
you have to say we're outside Boston and
then they say Harvard and you're like oh
that's very impressive and it is very
impressive and let's face it if I had
gotten into Harvard I absolutely would
have gone but like to say that I wasn't
gonna get into Harvard would be to
dramatically understate the situation
yeah no I did not I did not I did not
apply uh I did also I did go to school
outside Boston though so there's that
it's a I could I can also accurately say
that boy anyway did you go to school
outside Boston I went to school in a
place that wasn't
oh yeah you went to school like 2,400
miles outside Boston correct
almost everyone went to school outside
Boston it's true only our dad went to
school inside Boston this next question
comes from Julianna who asks dear John
and Hank in the most recent episode of
the pod Hank mentions that Mars is
moon's orbit near the equator this got
me thinking where does Earth's moon
orbit this is our special moon episode
by the way does it also orbit around the
equator this is kind of bothering me I
hope that she said it's kind of
bothering me like even Juliana can't
bring herself to be that worked up about
this but she did care enough to write in
I did I it was bothering her at the
moment it's not bothering her anymore
it's over no she's totally over it it is
it is a little bit non equatorial so if
it were in the pure elliptic plane we
would have an eclipse all like every
month
oh glut it's not so we don't get
eclipses occasionally so it's a little
bit tilted Hank is there anything else I
should know about the moon while we're
on the topic I mean a lot the moon is
really really great and you should like
all cold dead rocks and maybe it does
care about things maybe the moon is one
of us just hopefully it won't come down
to visit because that would be the end
ya know I read a book about that and
things were very very poor did you read
seven Eve's
no I read a different book about it
maybe maybe it's a frequent topic of
dystopic fiction but boy oh boy did it
make me not want the moon to get any
closer to Earth than it currently is all
right Hank let's move on to this
question from Joshua who asks Dear John
and Hank if hope is the thing with
feathers which bird is it or is it like
a dinosaur tear down this wall Joshua I
am so glad Joshua that you asked this
question because I've been wondering
this for so many years and never felt
like I that confidence necessary to ask
it all right well we can look at the
text of the poem Hank and we can learn
some things there's more that isn't just
that long line I thought that was just
that one line was the whole poem
no it's not a one line poem it the this
is the beginning
hope is the thing with feathers that
perches in the soul and sings the tune
without the words and never stops at all
so we know that and then later hope is
described as quote a little bird which
is also helpful okay aha
so we know that hope is probably not a
dinosaur because it is a little bright
now there were little birds in the
dinosaur era but we don't know much
about the tunes that they sang and we
know that this is a little bird that
sings a tune without records and that a
tune that's encouraging and a tune that
makes you feel lifted up in a tomb right
right and a tune that Emily Dickinson is
in some way aware of right and I can
imagine that currently exists Oh extinct
bird or an imaginary bird or a bird that
went extinct between Emily Dickinson
writing the poem and now write which is
totally possible because there's a bunch
of those yeah not it yeah yeah I
wouldn't say necessarily I'm betting
it's a passenger pigeon well definitely
that is one of the ones that isn't
around I don't know what a passenger
pigeon sounds like good okay couldn't
couldn't tell you well fortunately Hank
I have here right now the sound of a
passenger pigeon the sound of its song
as recorded by the Smithsonian did you
just google that no I just have it on my
computer at all times
hold on you have to listen to an ad
first you don't have you to read come on
I do have it this is not on youtube this
is on the Smithsonian calm oh my god
this ad does it end for 14 seconds
forget it it's not even worth it's not
even worth like show it on YouTube no
that's that's the story of the last
passenger pigeon I don't want to know
about Martha that sounds very sad just
tell me what they sound well I think I'm
not gonna be able to play you any
passenger pigeon sounds because
Smithsonian wanted me to watch a
30-second ad and I mean in this day and
age that's just
impossible we have a podcast to make
it's too much of my life 30 seconds I
get the last time I watched a full 30
second dad was like 2006 the idea that
educational institutions and I know that
I'm coming at this from an extremely
biased perspective but have to use
advertising to support themselves to me
just seems deeply unjust can't we
support these things I don't know like
the Smithsonian and certain YouTube
channels that are educational in a way
that they won't have to worry about
money can't society do that I completely
agree Hank and also I would like to say
a huge thank you to audible for
sponsoring today's podcast yeah yep
appreciate that it does help us make our
educational youtube videos at scishow
and crash course McKay asks dear Hank
John I'm sorry I said your name that way
McKay I'm worried about Lee on mus he
never tweets anymore is he unwell
perhaps from eating upwards of 400
Snickers bars or has he somehow
misplaced his antipathy for Mars
exploration which was his defining
characteristic back in town McKay Hank
when we on must first appeared on the
scene to advocate for an earth only
human species until at least 20 28 so
that this podcast can be renamed Dear
John and Hank it's true and rightful
name I remember you saying that Leon
must was just going to be a flash in the
pan somebody who didn't spend 13 years
on Twitter ceaselessly advocating for a
one planet solution to the human species
and I was convinced that you were wrong
and that I was going to keep that bit
alive for 12 years and this is
surprising and difficult to admit but
you were right Hank almost every time
I've ever believed in my heart that I
had found the solution to my social
media malaise I have been incorrect it
is interesting those moments when when
I'm starting a new thing and I'm so
excited about it and it's like this is
this is gonna be I got the I got the
long term fuel here I really know what
I'm up about now yeah and then yeah it
fades and you find a way to either make
it sustainable
you know you decide Leon it's hanging
out there just in case he's needed you
know and maybe neatly on will be needed
someday and and if ever he is he will be
back you know Hank among the blessings
that we inherited from our parents was
not a blessing toward long term
endeavors I mean is that because our
parents were not great at long term
endeavors I don't know I don't know
whose fault it is I'm just saying that
you and I almost always get bored of
whatever we're doing pretty quickly well
except for except apparently for our 12
year long video blog project John what
is Leon must doing right now like what's
his current his current job like what
like when he's not tweeting was he up to
oh well as you know Hank Leon muss is
working hard to make earth the number
one and only place that humans live that
that has two that has two jobs right
there's the one job which is keeping
humans from Mars so on that front he's
lobbying people in Congress people in
private industry to please just stop
trying to send people to Mars in such a
hurry we don't know that much about it
it's dangerous like let's just let's
take a pause on this and try for 2029
right that's the first thing that he's
doing the second thing he's doing is
working hard to try to make earth a
better place for humans from the long
haul because this whole notion of planet
B that there's going to be some kind of
like backup civilization is just
ludicrous and so Leon Moss is out there
every day talking to members of Congress
and people in private industry and
saying we've got to invest in earth Hank
I don't know if you saw this but Jeff
Bezos the CEO of Amazon yes which owns
audible.com which sponsors today's
podcast yeah in the interest of all full
disclosure
Jeff Bezos said that he didn't know how
to spend what he called his winnings
from Amazon now over a hundred billion
dollars because he didn't know what
kinds of problems to solve with that
amount of money and I have some ideas as
I'm sure you did Hank and certainly
Twitter
had a lot of ideas for him but he said
the main thing that I think we can do is
space exploration and I think that's
fine
and Leon must thinks that's fine but I
actually think is quite a bit of work to
do here on earth yeah that's what I
think yeah I mean I like I he had to
know right that people would be like
well well there's you know hungry people
I did genuinely is available available
for a price I think that a lot of super
wealthy people don't think that
philanthropy can solve those problems I
think that they're wrong but I think
that they think that I think I think
it's awfully convenient for them to
think that exactly and anytime you
believe something that also happens to
be extremely convenient for your
worldview you have to interrogate why
you believe it right and yeah that can
be a difficult and painful process and I
by the way like you and I are not in any
way exempt from that yeah absolutely and
I guess what I didn't realize is that
Leon mas is just independently wealthy
like he doesn't need a job job he could
just be out there at Congress knocking
on knocking on doors no no no okay well
I pay him I pay oh you're the he's your
lobbyist yeah this next question comes
from Dustin who asks dear Hank and John
for the last year so I've been
endeavoring to make the word toast
a popular greeting I'm not gonna read
the rest of this question it's just not
gonna happen
dust and yeah but I do like your own
specific sign-off the wind Dustin
cuz it's dust in the wind oh that's good
that's good work on making your name
specific sign-off happened Dustin I
don't think toast is gonna happen
because it's not an effective greeting
and also it doesn't fill a need like the
the thing about language is it has to
fill a place where we have an idea or a
feeling but there's no word that
adequately describes it or the words
that adequately describe it feel dated
and incorrect or cringy or whatever
right so like hello
has aged extraordinarily well but it's
not that old hello is fairly new and
it's sort of like we grew we got yeah I
think so
what did what did people used to say in
like Athenian grease were they like well
met sir
they were just like sup they said sup
sup sup is a greeting that did not yeah
actually now that I think about it why
not make toast work like well he's know
like 10 years I thought that I was gonna
mock Dustin but now I feel like I have a
plan first you have to change culture so
that a thing that we do when we see each
other instead of like like waving or
fist bumps or whatever cuz these things
change fist bumps weren't a thing when I
was a kid this is all very new is you
have to have the thing be giving someone
else a piece of toast and so that become
writing for a while is like every time
like you have a bag full of toast and
every time you see somebody I know you
have to throw this as host atom and then
language will evolve because that's
super inconvenient to just have the word
toast be the thing you say instead of
pegging somebody with hard bread right
so for the first generation or so we're
just going to have to institute this
social convention where everyone gives
each other toast Hank we I'm gonna stop
myself right there because what we are
risking is the next time we do a live
show a lot of people bringing us toast
that won't even be warm anymore because
it will have been toasted hours ago and
just throwing at us on stage just
hitting us with toast please don't bring
us we need a different we need a
different word it's not gonna be toast
we're in ending it no Dustin it's not
toast instead it's John go Snickers yeah
probably these diet dr. pepper not no
time doctor ever sounds dangerous
sharpies is at least useful 100,000
frequent flyer miles on Delta
that's like the standard gift exchange
whenever you see someone it's like hello
it's nice to see you I brought you
100,000 frequent flyer miles as a way of
saying greetings good oh man I do God I
I just I did just name all of the
corporations I have deep abiding almost
romantic relationships with like
corporations that when they do something
really wrong I feel like I've done
something a little bit wrong you know
where like if diet dr. pepper has an ad
campaign that I don't approve of or that
people people will come to me and
they'll be like hey have you seen those
new diet dr. pepper ads they're so
stupid I'll be like I know and I'll feel
like it's my fault
like I failed which reminds me that this
podcast is brought to you by John's
tremendous brand affinity Johnson
tremendous brand affinity it's
irrational but it's undeniable I do I
love me some particular corporations
today's podcast is also brought to you
by the thing with feathers the thing
with feathers a passenger pigeon
possibly and also today's podcast is
brought to you by the call of the
passenger pigeon apparently somebody
knows what it sounds like but we
couldn't figure it out and so we're just
gonna have Nick edited in here unless it
doesn't exist in which case Nick is
going to edit in the sound of a
different bird and we're all just gonna
pretend it's a passenger pigeon and
lastly today's podcast is brought to you
by the lunar month the lunar aunts 29.5
something something something days yes
accurate accurate ish and this podcast
has also brought to you by our actual
sponsor as we've discussed several times
during the podcast already audible
audible is a place where you can get
audio books and audio content and all
sorts of good things for your ears and
you can sign up for audible at
audible.com slash to your Hank or text
dear Hank to 500 500
and you can start your 30-day trial and
get a free audiobook John what are you
listening to an audible right for the
record you can also text dear John - 500
500 or go to audible.com slash dr3 on
lots and lots of audiobooks available
on audible including my books Turtles
all the way down and the fault in our
stars both narrated by Kate Rudd who's
such a brilliant narrator really the
book is much better when she reads it to
you then if you read it to yourself I at
the moment I'm listening to read Sparrow
Oh read spy novel book yeah what are you
listening to I'm listening to borderline
by Michelle Baker which jean is a very
cool weird fantasy novel about a person
with borderline personality disorder who
kind of ends up being the guard of the
border between the fairy realm and Los
Angeles oh wow that sounds kind of like
a border security agent for that and and
it's a sort of it's a mystery novel
mystery fantasy novel it's very very
cool and weird and it's first in a
series and I'm enjoying it a lot that's
great I love audible because you can get
pretty much any audiobook you want and
if you like me and you need to spend 10
to 20 hours a week either exercising or
in the garden in order to stay sane
audible is a great thing to keep you
company while you're planting your
vegetables or in my case planting your
vegetables that then freeze because it's
winter will never end in Indianapolis
they've got they've got basically every
genre of content they've got business
stuff I've listened to lots of science
books classics fiction history romance
thriller i listen i'm sort of slowly
making my way through every michael
connelly book which i've enjoyed
tremendously i even found a three pack
of three michael connelly books and you
can get the whole three pack with just
one audible credit so there's a protip
sometimes you can find packages of
audiobooks together you know so you
could do that at so you could do that
audible.com slash to your Hank or text
dear Hank - 500 500 - get started on
audible today Dear John also works thank
you again to audible for sponsoring
today's podcast and for supporting
podcasts all over the place Hank this
next question comes from Tori who writes
Dear John and Hank recently I've been in
pursuit of straighter teeth and
Invisalign invisible aligners have been
aiding me however every two weeks I have
to put in
tray and my dentist requested that I
keep all the former trays so presently I
have accumulated seven trays and I'm
starting to get worried at the end of
this pursuit I will have acquired 23
plastic molds of my ever-changing teeth
my question is what do I do with 23
plastic molds of my teeth do I string
them together to make a Christmas tree
garland do I help them all down to form
one mega teeth tray and he do be suffice
is greatly appreciated
too many teeth trays Tori ah yeah art
you got a art it right I mean that's
certainly one option heck I think the
obvious thing to do here is the next
time Tori you're in a romantic
relationship
you give your new partner all 23 plastic
molds of your former teeth on your one
week anniversary okay good good or or we
can change human society so that every
time you see a friend on the street you
have to throw a plastic tooth tray at
them that's a great idea Hank and
eventually instead of saying hello will
say tooth trays the other thing I like
about that idea Hank is that it
increases the possibility from zero to
unacceptably high that at some point in
the future someone will give us a tooth
tray when we are doing live shows so I
want to tell you nonzero number is
unacceptably high like that used to be
zero we used to be in the wonderful
world where there was a zero percent
chance of anyone ever giving us their
dental equipment and now we are not in
that world anymore man I can't tell you
how much I want to go back to that past
where I was definitely never gonna get a
stranger's dental trays I all right Hank
I believe I believe that you did this to
yourself John
I I guess so and Torrie I'm with Hank
deep down you should definitely art this
situation Hank before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
wilded we need to issue one extremely
important correction which is those two
hundred thousand people rode in P and P
in a sign-off last week somebody signed
off P and P comma their name
and Hank and I thought it had something
to do with drugs and partying and young
people and we were just out of touch
middle-aged people but in fact the
explanation is so much more obvious
which is that P and P stood for pumpkins
and penguins an inside dear Hank and
John joke so old that apparently both
Hank and I have forgotten it more
evidence that we are well and truly
middle-aged my favorite part of this
this letter particularly from Ann is
that she called she said oMG
P and P obviously means pumpkins and
penguins you actual doofus ODEs I know
now we're doofus oeid in my life which
is way which is a huge gift and thank
you very much yeah thank you and III am
a doofus oeid and I need that word to
describe myself so much like yeah I've
already started using doofus oeid to
describe myself to my children and of
course immediately they got it and they
were like yes that is yes our dad that
does what happened to me as I thought
Pride and Prejudice and I couldn't get
it out of my head and I couldn't think
of anything except for because that's
what P and P is and my you know pre dear
Hank and John life sure sure
well Hank before we get to your news
from Mars I have a bit of news from Mars
which is that I think you may remember
that a while ago six or seven human
beings went to live on the side of a
volcano in Hawaii for a year inside of a
very small dome in an attempt to figure
out what it would be like to spend a
year in a very small dome on Mars and
those people it turns out all along
we're sending recordings once a week to
a radio reporter who has now turned it
into a podcast called the habitat and it
is a I think it's seven episodes long
and it's very very enjoyable and also a
fascinating glimpse into how social
dynamics start to work when people are
extremely isolated and have to live with
each other for a year without really any
much of any input from the outside world
so I really enjoyed it and I recommend
checking out the habitat and in in
other Mars news the big Mars news right
now is that when this podcast comes out
the Mars insight Lander will have
launched hopefully and everything will
have gone gone according to plan so
we're recording this on Friday so that
launched has having tomorrow for me and
I'm very nervous about it
Mars insight Lander is going to mostly
be studying the interior of Mars and
it's the first Lander we will ever have
that will like basically use like a like
a you know those like grabby things at
the movie theater that you can try to
grab a stuffed animal
your skills oh yeah it's basically got a
skill claw and it's gonna skill cause
some stuff off the lander onto the
ground and then have it sort of sit
there unconnected from the lander and it
will be hopefully much easier than an
actual skilled claw and also it should
be said that's actual skill claws
involved very little skill because
they're just programmed to not grab
except like one time out of seven it's
all eyes and the and it will put a
seismometer on the surface of Mars to
sit there and measure things by the
interior of Mars a seismometer works
like this if you want to know what what
the land looks like under you you can
send a very like powerful shockwave
through the land and by the way that it
bounces back at you you can tell the
densities of of the rock at different
depths but it's you know it to get
deeper to get as deep as you can you
need a really powerful shock and in fact
the most powerful shock you can get is
an earthquake and so seismometers work
by measuring how earthquakes move
through a planet Wow
and and there are Mars quakes and so
basically this thing will sit there
waiting for good good earthquakes to
good Mars quakes to happen and when good
marsquakes happens the the that that
rumbling will travel through Mars and
get bounced back up toward the
seismometer in a way that will allow
scientists to determine the density of
rock and the interior of the planet Mars
which we just we have no idea and so
Mars is not it doesn't have plate
tectonics it has not had plate tectonics
for a long time or maybe ever
but it does
it is geologically active it does have
earthquakes and we don't really know why
or how or what's on the inside and so
this will allow us that first glimpse
beyond just like basically a few feet
below the surface well that's really
exciting Hank it's gonna be cool to know
what Mars quakes are like it never
occurred to me until I heard you say
that that earthquakes are an earth
specific phenomenon yeah yeah well I
mean it was sort of a decision people
had to make where we gonna call them
earthquakes on the moon and earthquakes
on them on Mars or we're gonna give them
moon quake in Mars quake and we decided
to go with moon quick and Mars quake I
dig it I like Mars quakes so the news
from AFC Wimbledon Hague has already
noted AFC Wimbledon have secured Ligue 1
status for next year with 52 points and
exactly 52 points they play on Saturday
and if they win they'll end the season
with 55 points which will be great but
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter at
all I don't care in the least what
happens on Saturday as long as nobody
gets hurt and everyone has a good time
they secured Ligue 1 status with a nil
nil draw against Doncaster that was
maybe the most excruciating ly slow two
hours of my life Doncaster did never
seemed very close to scoring but that
did not stop me from worrying
it was extremely tense and the
celebrations
I gotta get close once that's right the
celebrations at the end of the game were
really really wonderful you know it
means a lot to Wimbledon fans to to stay
up of course it means that you know
we're only one year away now hopefully
from the opening of the new stadium the
new play lane which will completely
transform Wimbledon's ability to compete
in Ligue 1 and perhaps beyond so if we
can just find a way to stay up for one
more season then we'll have the new
Platt Lane and all of its opportunities
and revenue and fanciness to help us you
know grow from there it's been an
incredibly stressful and difficult
season not least for the players the
manager knee largely said after the game
that having been through a playoff final
and now through a real relegation scrap
that this was far more stressful on
every level it was really
for the players and I went through on
Twitter after the game and and thanked
each of the players because I know that
it's it's been a really hard season for
them and that's they really have stayed
together and that's why women are gonna
have another season in the league's in
Ligue 1 so I'm really psyched I'm really
relieved now of course the question
immediately turns to will Wimbledon be
able to hold on to their star players
especially Lyle Taylor who has interest
from championship clubs clubs in the
division above where we are now so that
maybe it's hard to tell you know Lyle
after all he's done for this team that
he you know can't play at the highest
level that he can play at so I don't
know I don't know if we'll be able to
hold on to him and then George Wang the
goalkeeper who also had a wonderful
season is on loan from Sheffield United
so we don't know what's gonna happen
there it's gonna be an interesting
offseason but oh my gosh is it gonna be
easier being in league 1 again yeah I'm
very happy and I was very happy when it
happened and I'm actually I'm looking
forward to this this game that doesn't
matter between AFC Wimbledon and Barry
or burry or whatever so yeah like it can
be a game where you don't have to be
super nervous into I know finally like 2
hours of football that can be enjoyed
many times this season so that that
should be good they have halftime they
have halftime yes do they what do they
do during how do they have like bands
come out on the field and like do dad it
at their thing occasionally they'll have
they'll have stuff happen at halftime
but often they like until I snot like
the middle school band from the local
local town come out to I've never seen
that in particular although I couldn't
say for certain but yeah sometimes stuff
happens at halftime honestly when I go
to a game I usually spend a half-time
waiting in line for the bathroom and
getting a beer so you've no idea what
happens at all okay yeah so I wouldn't
be able to tell you for sure Hank what
did we learn today oh wait what was your
phrase of the week John what was your
phrase of the week I'm gonna guess that
yours was a hundred thousand Delta
frequent flyer miles or whatever you
said no it was the Athenian democracy I
don't even remember you getting or the
Athenian grease or whatever I said
okay yep yep I squeezed it in of course
I have no flippin idea what yours was
because I never listened to what you're
saying
[Laughter]
what was it I'm not even gonna guess it
was middle school band I said it like oh
my god old school band I wasn't even
listening twenty five seconds ago enough
to guess I mean it's not like it's hard
to figure out gah mm-hmm so mad myself
looks like it was like okay the podcast
is ending oh god how do i how do I give
middle school band in here right now
Hank for reasons for reasons that will
become obvious probably in the next week
or two I have to go right now to be on a
very important conference call so okay
you're gonna do the intro well everyone
except for John thank you for listening
to the podcast and John thank you for
potting with me even though you're not
there anymore thanks to audible for for
for helping us out and also for being a
great service that I enjoy using
audible.com slash dear Hank and John
can't tell you any different or text
dear Hank to 500 500 also we have snappy
the don't snappin text t-shirts
available at dftba.com cuz why not have
that they are available for pre-order
for a limited time and then they won't
be available anymore and to do hope that
I someday see somebody besides me
wearing one but that's of course
entirely up to you this podcast is
edited by nicholas jenkins our producers
are rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our head of community and
communications is Victoria bon giorno
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]